[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
merci j'en juge mais un canapé bravo là
on a rien compris
merci à l'occasion des 25 ans voilà wise
as à bas voilà aimé isabelle commenté
frêche
ils ont mis ils ont remis tous les
chroniqueurs ils sont dix ans les noms
de maniora tout le monde sait en deux
jours nous aurons tout le week-end à
l'évêché à l'occasion des 25 ans 100
jeunes à une idée de cette nouvelle
séquence longue et tous les jours savais
tu es pmp c'est avant tout une famille
vous faites partie
la famille bien entendu donc chaque soir
un chroniqueur va demander aux autres un
conseil sur sa vie privée sur sa vie
professionnelle et on va l'aider à
prendre une décision importante
aujourd'hui c'est moi qui vais me
tourner vers vous et je vous posais une
question c'est à vous de m'aider à me
dire ce que vous pensez vous aussi chez
ou dois-je arrêté et pmp l'année
prochaine puisque ce sera la onzième
saison
vous savez que j'arrive en fin de
contrat sur s'est vite voilà en tant
qu'animateur donc se peut arrêter en fin
de saison
qu'est ce que vous en pensez dites moi
et je vous dirai moi ce que j'en pense
aussi après avoir eu vos avis différent
on va démarrer par valide alors valérie
votera nettement oui je pense qu'il faut
pas que vous arrêtiez votre métier
d'animateur mais que vous êtes au bout
d'une émission qui fait 10 ans c'est un
très joli chiffre est qu'il faut pas
faire l'année de trop donc je me dis que
disantes pmp et ensuite créer une
nouvelle marque inventer une nouvelle
émission vous réinventez aussi et
refaire une autre émission qui serait
pas touche pas à mon poste mais qui
serait un nouveau cyril hanouna pourront
à nouveau dix nouvelles années pour 10
pour une nouvelle émission donc sur vous
abat donc sans moi pourquoi la main ou
avec vous ou avec moi si vous avez envie
de continuer ensemble en tout cas
françois viot ben non moi de revenir
pour la
mais de revenir pour la 11eme oui ça
fait quatre ans qu'on vous dit pas faire
la saison de trop
et en fait la 10e ça a été la rentrée la
plus extraordinaire donc continuer et
moi je suis déçu de la partie allait ben
on lui pense à losail l'avez compris
c'est vous eric naulleau
moi je viens d'arriver donc vous dites
j'ai envie de vous dire qu'il déconnait
cyril avec des questions comme ça oui
elle produira t'inquiète pas non moi moi
j'estime que quand vous posez la
question vous dit peut-être une nouvelle
émission mais sans les chroniqueurs
présents six mois ça n'a pas de sens si
vous voulez vous renouveler et vous avez
des nouveaux contenus étaient peu ou pas
bon pour moi ça a pas l'air d'être une
émission essoufflé d'après l'ambiance
sur le plateau d'après les audiences
donc j'ai pas l'impression
moi ça me rend dingue à chaque fois les
émissions qui s'arrête alors que ça
marche encore très bien et comme ses
limites ce qui marchait très bien tous
les jours encore et en plus on a fait
comme a dit françois on a fait une super
rentrée dont jean-paul quoi elle
s'arrêterait bonjour clos ce match vous
a trouvé en mathieu 70 battu barakat est
objectivement cette édition elle marche
très bien
un million deux amis ont trois millions
quatre mois à votre place
une chose qui marche sur du quai à ce
niveau là je n'arrêterai pas maintenant
est ce que cela continue sur cette
chaîne ou sur une autre
c'est une autre discussion et c'est à
vous et vous pourrez vous aussi roux qui
avait les clés auxerre mon avis
professionnel voilà tu penses à quelle
chaîne je ne pense pas c'est celle qui
porte à gastes non je pense que vous
n'en avez pas envie en plus je pense que
c'est une décision que vous prendrez
avec vos fans mais après ce qui est vrai
avec vous c'est que vous n'êtes pas un
michel drucker ou interdits sont pas
dans le talent bien sûr vous n'avez rien
à leur envier
mais dans la dépendance à l'antenne vous
n'êtes pas dépendants à l'antenne vrai
il ya des animateurs comme vous qui ont
beaucoup de succès et qui ne veulent
absolument pas raccrocher parce que la
télé c'est la vie passée à la télé c'est
la vie faire des émissions c'est la vie
vous c'est pas le cas bon tant que
producteur oui mais ce qui est vrai
c'est que vous faites aussi plein de
choses à côté vous avez très envie
d'aider les gens vous avez envie
pourquoi pas diriger un groupe ou une
chaîne aussi donc coeur du ping pong
aussi maintenant à voir en fonction de
ce qui vous fait vibrer style vraiment
genre envie de dire d'arrêter parce que
c'est beau d'arrêter en pleine gloire
c'est beau de se dire je me barre à 1
million
un million 3 salut aux rideaux et je
fais autre chose et je vous ai découvert
et comme tout le monde dans balances ton
post et c'est vrai on se comporte des
gens qui vous ont découvert là dessus
dit ça quand même
il est fort parce qu'il tient le débat
il donne la parole à des gens donc pour
cette raison j'ai envie que ça s'arrête
mais la raison que j'ai prouvé que ça
s'arrête c'est quand tu parle avec les
gens les gens te disent vous êtes ma
bouffée d'oxygène le soir ça fait du
bien j'attends de vous voir ja ça me
fait oublier mes problèmes
j'ai eu des journées de merde les dettes
tout ça ils se posent devant la télé et
ça leur fait du bien
alors n'en déplaise à ceux qui disent
hanouna ces deux guignols c'est pourri
on met des perruques et settat et c'est
ça plaît à des gens donc pour cette
raison
ba continue continue pour les gens alors
isabelle deux ans plus tard sont
terminées par le meilleur à la va-vite
le vasistas que hanouna c'est un label
que tpm paix c'est un label et qui
s'arrêtera si vous avez envie que ça
s'arrête mais de toute façon et ça ne
vous a jamais empêché de faire quoi que
ce soit à côté
donc je vois pas pourquoi te pmp
marchand ça s'arrêterait donc ce sera un
non sens il est de dire faut pas faire
ma n'est trop beau à faire un trou bah
oui c'est valable pour tout le monde
mais pourquoi ne pas la faire si ce
n'est pas l'année de trop donc ces
imbéciles
[Rires]
c'est comme toi tu arrives en boîte les
mecs qui te 19 ans pour les habituer
mais si je rentre pas jordi d'écoles et
des bas mais non c'est pour les habitués
oui mais bon j'ai envie d'être habitué
je voulais oui bah laissez moi et me tue
je leur ai tout le temps battus le vrai
succès c'est de savoir créer le manque
si tu pars maintenant toute ta vie tu
entendras quel dommage que tpm paix se
soit arrêté si par hasard tu restes un
peu trop sur entendrait c'était bien
mais à la fin on n'en pouvait plus de
tpm paix tu as le succès tu l'auras
toujours tu as l'argent tu as le
charisme tu as notoriété à la part en
eau en eau en haut de la fiche et je
vois pas comment tu peux être plus
qu'aujourd'hui et des gens ici ça me
ferait chier parce que ça s'arrêterait à
la fin de l'année tu ferais autre chose
tavi s'arrêterait pas mais créer le
manque
oui avec moi je t'ai laissé la parole à
jean mi parce que celui qui avec moi
depuis le début mine de rien je pense
qu'on arrêtera ensemble à bavois
j'arrêterai en tout cas on va t'on vous
c'est sûr voilà donc la lan est trop
chou ce com comme les autres ça peu bête
c'est comme le verre de trop pour savoir
qu'il était trop quand faut-il avoir vu
qu'on l'a pas bien on sait pas quand je
n'écoute jamais vu et je crois pas que
cyril tu comme tu le dit mathieu gens il
faut qu'il n'y pense pas on georges bach
était en pleine gloire excitera je pense
qu'il a tissé un tel lien c'est la seule
émission je pense de l'histoire du paf
qui a créé un tel lien avec les
téléspectateurs
je pense que vous ne sentez même plus
maître de votre destin je pense que les
téléspectateurs qui nous arrêterons
géant presque vides hier ce que je pense
pas que vous sentiez encourage les
abandonner en plein milieu du gué parce
que ça touche pas à mon poste ne savons
pas son but est toujours au poste donc
je pense que tant qu'ils auront un
appétit bien vous aussi envie de vous
abandonner
voilà surtout les fans mais je pense que
les spectateurs si vous avez un lien
très proche pour ce soit le week-end
toul en vacances vous les voyez tout le
temps vous avez un vrai lien avec eux
comme aucune autre émission d'avant je
pense que vous sentir plus serait pas le
courage d'arrêter le temps qu'ils auront
envie de vous alors il n'a pas ma
décision je vous le dis je l'ait déjà
prises ah ah ah bon moi j'ai déjà pris
ma décision je le mange mes cheveux ou
là je voulais dire je vais voir ce qu'on
pense des téléspectateurs tu as aidé
aujourd'hui oui celle à dire aujourd'hui
80%
oui donc ils voudraient que tout
continue et ai pu me placer le jeune
louis à 80 % non à 20% parfait
donc je vous dis il ya eu beaucoup
beaucoup de vote moi j'ai beaucoup
réfléchi pendant cet été je me suis dit
je vais voir comment roule la saison 10
sachets l'on sait jamais autant amusé
que lors de cette saison c'est
incroyable ce qui se passe voilà tous
les joueurs d'ailleurs
l'émission n'a jamais aussi bien marché
et merci d'être aussi fidèle le truc
c'est quoi la mouche fini l'année sur
ces huit là 6 et 8 a besoin de moi bien
entendu je continuerai sur ces 8 avec
vous dans tpm paix et si les
téléspectateurs sont toujours là et
qu'ils ont envie de nous voir
je vois je me vois pas arrêter ce que je
pense que ça va être un énorme manque
pour moi mine de rien d'arrêté tpm pays
d'avoir le direct tous les soirs et
créer une nouvelle marque pourquoi créer
une nouvelle marque alors que tp mine de
rien voilà tout faire de long et que on
peut se jouer au ceci bien avec les
boîtes que que faire des livres ou des
baous faire des trucs plus sérieux voilà
comment on fait dans l'émission
aujourd'hui on a créé trois émissions en
une
donc voilà donc c'est vrai que créer une
nouvelle marque qu'une connerie
maintenant 6 et 8 me dit
on souhaite de se séparer de toi pour
diverses raisons voilà on sait pas ce
que va faire la chaîne tête la chaîne va
aller vers un une autre ligne éditoriale
voilà bien sûr je ferai
j'essaierai de faire cette émission
ailleurs voilà mais en tout cas c'est
pas on va en discuter avec ces huit là
dans les prochains mois et je vous dirai
voilà ce qu'il en est bien entendu les
chéris mois là mais en tout cas voilà je
suis plutôt de l'avis de jean michel
voilà de keddy d'algues hâte de benjamin
de raymond aussi voilà d'isabelle enfin
je suis pas l'avis de match de ceux qui
ont besoin de fric en fait que des avis
de s'occuper d'autrui bah oui mais voila
voila je vous le dis donc voila merci en
tout cas d'avoir répondu